les médecins de la clinique sainte-marie
monte au créneau depuis quelques jours
ils font entendre leur voix à travers un
collectif qu'ils ont créé l'objectif
mettre en avant l'offre de soins
proposés par l'établissement dans lequel
il propose des services qui ne sont pas
proposées ailleurs on peut parler de la
pma la progression médicalement assistée
qui n'existe d'ailleurs qui n'existe
plus au gré de l'hôpital incendie du chu
nous avons un service de médecine qui
est très compétent et qui permet aux
patients qui sortent par exemple d'un
infarctus de venir faire des bilans ou
la rééducation cardiaque sans difficulté
le communiqué insiste la fermeture de la
structure serait une catastrophe
sanitaire
l'établissement est le seul à disposer
d'un robot pour opérer les cancers de la
prostate dont la prévalence est élevé en
martinique
l'offre de soin en martinique étant déjà
pauvres globalement par rapport à
l'hexagone avec de fortes disparités
une un manque de spécialistes un manque
de généralistes alors pour les
spécialistes l'ordre d'environ 20 à 30 %
de moins que par rapport à l'hexagone
la perte d'un établissement comme la
clinique sainte-marie serait vraiment
terrible dommageable pour le système
sanitaire de la martinique de la
chirurgie de l'obésité à la radiologie
la clinique sainte-marie se veut
accessible à tous grâce à des tarifs
abordables mais la structure connaît de
grandes difficultés financières qui ont
déjà conduit à plusieurs grèves en 2017
l'établissement est en cessation de
paiement depuis un mois et un plan
social est annoncé dans quelques jours
c'est le tribunal de commerce qui
devrait se prononcer sur une possible
liquidation judiciaire